experience does the truth come out
eventually when it comes to cheating
for men and for women both both it comes
out i disagree it could take years yeah
women
i'm saying if you're still together
yeah yeah right because
both partners at some point in time
can feel an energy change
like doesn't matter it doesn't matter
like you know if you you're you're
married right yeah you know your
partner's
and you know you know you know what he
does everything every day you know his
movements
you can feel a shift and be like that's
a bit yeah different right because
my last relationship was ten years
i might as well be married but
yeah i'm saying okay i i knew the
logistics of someone you know i mean and
they knew my logistics so if the
logistics got
started going a little bit funny like
either of us
oh you didn't
explain and when would you say it was
the same with like friends of yours that
have cheated or like men women both ways
does it catch up to them eventually do
you know if it if if people don't find
out
um
tell them i think i think
it might catch up with you at some point
that's what like that was my feeling
because i just feel like you can't run
from yourself and at some point and at
some point your habits catch up to you
and like if you're going to be married
for 40 50 years what are the odds that
you keep it a secret the whole time
some people don't actually find out
until like
they've passed like at the funeral but
that's still there that's for men that's
for men
i mean like that's still like i know
people that have gone to funerals and
found siblings yeah do you know what i
mean but that's it's still catching up
yeah you cut there's only so long you
can hide from the truth yeah and so even
so that's your legacy and if you don't
if you don't some people don't care
they're like whatever the whole thing
yeah yeah
and another thing as well that i feel a
lot of people don't pay attention to
especially women that are married and be
cheating on their husbands
when a woman cheats on their husband
i don't know maybe call me superstitious
or whatever but
what i've seen in the past is them like
the man he's just not normal his stuff
starts messing up
finances like he's
like a woman cheating on her husband you
mess him up
sorry you mess him up
physically spiritually for like uh
financially
if he finds out not just when he finds
out when you start doing it
it happens
that's not that's that's why they say
when a woman cheats it's it's if it's
more dangerous than a man
it is but when a man cheese oh oh he's
cheating oh no because a man can because
a man's cheating is not emotional it's
not emotional one and secondly
now a woman's cheated you're sleeping
with these two men unprotected you get
pregnant
whose baby is it do not mean it's not
natural
it's not natural for a woman to cheat on
her husband so you bring all this bad
luck yeah
i'm baggage on your husband i have a
question would you guys stay with your
husbands if um he stepped out yeah oh
sorry she said no she said no hesitation
and i let him know that no good on you
man okay i'll be good
how many times i'm leaning more towards
yes
i i think mainly because i there i feel
like there's a strong theme of
forgiveness
and i'm not i'm not saying that that
justifies you you cheating but i i would
hope that there is something in within
myself that could offer forgiveness now
if you're a serial cheater then yeah how
many hall passes
there's no hall it's not about hall
passes
you both just gave them all
it's the it's the element of forgiveness
i think this probably comes from faith
right you you have to
there is an element of forgiving that is
important for our marriage anyway the
the element of forgiveness we don't hold
grudges we don't hold that i'm not
saying that it's okay for him to cheat
but what i'm saying is that forgiveness
is a key value in our marriage as long
as he's still treating you as his wife
wait so what about you what if um
there's more women than men in this
world no i'm saying like is unlimited he
could cheat as many times as long as
it's not emotional you don't care as
long as he's doing it he's coming back
to you right he's coming back to me and
i don't know i'm the misses and let's
let you know what we're all
obviously where we come from
historically men married two three
four what is it because thousand years
ago it won 8 000 years
it was 2-3 and he's saying 8 000 years
ago it was even further where it was 17
for everyone
and how long did he live
don't worry about that
well it was because of rulers and
emperors like gangas khan i think would
you know mess up the distribution
because they would have hundreds of them
yeah so i i don't know what it was for
the average guy but but 40 of you you're
correct 40 of men have reproduced
historically where 80 80 to 90 percent
of women have
yeah
and plus you know
there's a book called out of eden
um by a guy called uh
david
barash don't i think his name is barash
but he was saying that prior to like the
western
one-man one yes right
most cultures
were living in some kind of poliginous
or polygamous
um relationship so that's what we have
been doing more so than this one man one
woman thing this thing is this is this
one one woman thing is really new